[Music]
I think it's a major threat because
democracy is based on the idea that
people make informed choices between
political options
[Music]
the first step should be that they are
aware of that threat exists but there
are actually people out there trying to
try to fool us trying to lie to us
trying to affect our opinions on
different matters so and being aware of
these techniques is a very good start
the first thing you got to worry about
is whether a person who's sending you
information is actually who they pretend
to be and it turns out that very often
on Twitter at least a lot of accounts
are fake they don't even exist they're
not real people they're just out there
for propaganda purposes and now
fortunately they're actually fairly easy
to identify because if somebody is
tweeting 20,000 tweets a day then
chances are they're not a human being
chances are that they're a
remote-controlled device that is trying
to disseminate propaganda
one motive could be to saw division to
make it look like opposing views on an
issue are very far apart and of course
if these views are perceived as being
very far apart it's much harder for us
to reach agreements and to move forward
and sold these issues it is aiming to
drive us apart and to make society more
polarized and less reasoned in its
decision-making
many of these things are designed to
evoke emotions so one basic rule could
be if you see something online and that
makes you furious for example then all
the more reason to to check the source
and check if this is actually true or
not so check yourself and see your
what's your emotional responses and
chances are that over the top the motive
information was probably not sent to you
for good-faith purposes
inoculation is just like an inoculation
against the flu or measles or whatever
else you're exposed ahead of time to a
small dose of the disinformation by
someone pointing out to you how you're
being dissing formed and then once you
understand the strategies that people
use to dis inform you then you can spot
it and then you can resist you have to
be aware that there are people trying to
deceive us on purpose they have lots of
resources and they are very very
creative so if we're fooled once or
twice there's nothing strange about that
but what we can do is to warn others we
when we find out that something is fake
or that something is different this
information don't spread it don't click
on it don't engage with
democracy is based on the idea of a
marketplace of ideas that is we're out
there talking to each other in public
and the debate sorts out the good ideas
from the bad ideas but if the ideas are
sent to people in darkness without
scrutiny without rebuttal
then you no longer have a marketplace of
ideas then you have manipulation on a
large scale I don't know but I can tell
that it is a motive so if it is a motive
why don't we just make it a little
harder to share it
how about it takes two seconds for the
share button to become available and you
have to look at a swirly thing on the
screen for two seconds you can cancel
anytime and if you do want to share it
you just gotta wait
don't care do not click share' do not
share stuff unless you know it's true
[Music]
you